Speaker 1: We're starting today with the president.
Yes, the president, Joe Biden, who is showing
more signs of life than we've seen for months
from the standpoint of his presidency.
Joe Biden, riding high on a number of major
accomplishments, went to Wilkes-Barre, Pennsylvania,
yesterday, and he absolutely crushed Republicans,
Republicans who are now openly threatening
violence.
We covered two days ago Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham saying if Trump is indicted,
there will be riots in the street.
Yeah, it'll be Trumpists rioting in the streets.
We know Lindsey and Joe Biden with I have
to say, I you know, I'm not adding a value
judgment to this, but Joe Biden more fired
up an energetic I would argue that I have
seen him his entire presidency as we are now,
just weeks from the 2022 midterms on which
so much ride.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Let me say this to my MAGA Republican
friends in Congress.
Yeah.
Don't tell me you support law enforcement.
If you all condemn what happened on the sixth.
Right.
Don't tell me.
Can't do it.
For God's sake, whose side are you on?
Not long.
Cause side are you on?
Look.
Simple.
Here you are, on the side of a mob, on the
side of the police.
You can't be pro law enforcement and pro insurrection.
You can't be a party of law and order and
call the people who attacked the police on
January six.
Patriots Right.
You can't do it.
What are we teaching our children?
It's just that simple.
But now it's sickening to see the new attacks
and the FBI threatening life as law enforcement
agents and their families for simply carrying
out the law and doing their job.
Look.
Speaker 1: Listen, we saw this type of thing
from California Governor Gavin Newsom about
a month ago.
And I told you that without endorsing his
entire political worldview, that it was the
exact right approach to dealing with these
modern MAGA Republicans.
Democrats have to be aggressive.
Democrats in some cases have to be ruthless.
It doesn't mean we do the things they do.
We don't tell lies we don't dare.
But we have to adopt this approach.
And Democrats should be looking at the approach
that Gavin Newsom is taking.
Democrats should be looking at this particular
version of Joe Biden.
And just think about the opposite for a second.
Imagine if you had Democrats openly threatening
law enforcement in the way that Republicans
have done.
After January, January 6th, excuse me, after
the search warrant being carried out at Mar
a Lago, just as the Republicans would be saying,
forget about due process.
Throw them in prison for life.
And I was glad to also see Joe Biden call
out Lindsey Graham.
Lindsey Graham, who predicted by which I mean
threatened or promised riots if Donald Trump
were to be indicted.
It's a great thing that Joe Biden is going
right after him as well.
Speaker 2: No one expects politics to be a
patty cake.
Hey, sometimes he is mean is hell.
But the idea you turn on the television is
to senior senators and congressmen saying
if such and such happens, there will be blood
in the street.
Where the hell are we?
Speaker 1: Right.
And of course, a direct reference there to
Lindsey Graham.
This is a much more interesting Joe Biden.
Look at the Joe Biden of the last three months.
Number one, rhetorically fiery, again energetic,
accomplished more during his COVID isolation
than Trump did his entire presidency, if you
can imagine that.
And now we see a great jobs report.
Inflation is down.
Gas prices are down.
The Inflation Reduction Act has been passed.
The Pact Act, the infrastructure bill.
I mean, I could go on and on.
I'm not going to give you the full list every
single time.
But accomplishment after accomplishment after
accomplishment.
This is a very different Joe Biden than we
saw earlier in the presidency or sort of in
the middle of the presidency.
And it's also a Democratic Party whose chances
in November of 2022 are looking dramatically
better.
So we're going to follow it very closely.
And by the way, in the middle of all of this.
We are seeing some Republicans, some Republicans
so disgusted by the low quality candidates
that their primary voters have selected to
represent them in November, that in some races,
Republicans are increasingly endorsing Democrats.
And that's what we're going to talk about
next.